[Musique]
après le droit à l'avortement la pilule
abortive est dans le viseur des
conservateurs
nous ferons tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour s'assurer que les femmes
américaines puissent prendre leur propre
décision et
la suspension par un juge fédéral nommé
par Donald Trump de la pilule la plus
utilisée pour l'avortement aux
États-Unis à l'effet d'une bombe dans le
camp démocrate
une décision qui pour cette élue
démocrate ne se base sur aucune nouvelle
étude écrasait des sorts
et pour laquelle le locataire de la
Maison Blanche Joe Biden ne restera pas
mobile
la pilule abortive me fait pristone a
été approuvé par l'agence américaine du
médicament il y a plus de 20 ans cette
décision du juge Matsu kasmeric survient
après le dépôt d'un recours collectif
contre la FDA par un groupe anti
avortement à sa cour en novembre dernier
le groupe proche à l'agence d'avoir
failli en approuvant un médicament qui
selon lui pose des risques pour la santé
des patients
nous sommes satisfaits que la justice
fédérale examine enfin la probation de
la mi-fi Stone et demandez compte à la
FDA dit-il
vendredi un autre jeu fédéral situé dans
l'État de Washington a émis une décision
contraire dans laquelle il appuie que le
médicament ne peut être interdit dans
les États qui le permettent le ministère
américain de la Justice de son côté a
décidé de porter cette décision en appel
particulièrement pendant
l'administration de Donald Trump
justement on est plusieurs instances ou
des fois on avait un jugement d'une
courbe de première instance et la
demande à leur appel elle est
directement la course c'est très
possible qu'on tente quelque chose la
sorte mais écoutez combien de jours de
semaine voir deux mois que ça va prendre
c'est très incertain ce qui rend
davantage l'avenir de cette pilule
abortive tout aussi incertaine aux
États-Unis ici Daniel cadjo Radio-Canada
Montréal